this elon musk cryptocurrency just went
on national television to tell people
their grannies should invest their life
savings into it what gives you the
confidence that someone should for
instance bring their grandmother in it
with their life savings
we have the huge community behind us so
you know think about the utility we're
the only token out there that has a
board of advisory you know like you know
that came into crypto have never been
part of the project that actually see
the beneficial side of this wow that's
awful and it gets so much
worse there's some amazing moments in
here like people in lab coats that are
doing nothing
rocket ships that don't work but the
real question is how did we get here on
fox business channel shilling an obvious
scam telling grandma to invest well what
you're looking at is elon goat token and
to understand how it came about you have
to understand that there's a new type of
human being out there whose entire
personality and career is made out of
loving and or hating elon musk you
probably have seen these people they
can't shut up about the fact that elon
musk is going to take them to mars next
year or that everything elon musk has
done has been a scam parlayed by his
father's emerald mind and part of the
motivation here is obviously to farm
attention for themselves because elon
musk is a big personality with followers
and if they can just get daddy's retweet
maybe they too can become big and famous
and this is sort of the strategy of a
lot of shameless people and
cryptocurrencies out there which have
tried to tie their financial success to
elon musk it's a whole category of new
grifter for example floki inu was named
after elon musk's dog they named a
crypto coin after elon musk tweeted
about his future scandal elon gate and
immediately it became a thing in fact
it's kind of a known fact at this point
that if elon musk farts it will quickly
gain a billion dollar market cap before
everyone figures out it's just hot air
and yes i too thought we were past all
of this as a species but apparently i
was wrong because there's another elon
musk token to add to the ranks of
worthless coins inter elon goat token if
you're one of those people that miss out
on sheba or doge it's time to take a
really good look at elon go token
because we're building him a massive
monument and we're delivering it to him
at tesla in austin texas that's it
that's the whole plan elon goat is going
to build a non-functional rocket ship
put a goat on it with elon musk's head
attached to it and they're going to
drive it to the tesla factory and demand
that elon musk accept their offering
that's their wording this is the thing
in 2022 that's supposed to make you
financially independent and they even
have a 3d rendering of it which just
shows you how dumb and terrible it all
really is this is supposed to be
what catapults you to financial success
this is what big business in 2022 looks
like a marketing stunt i guess and
before we get to the fox business
segment which is absolutely insane let's
just think for two seconds about this
plan this rocket ship they're building
doesn't work obviously right um and they
want to give it to a guy who builds
real rocket ships they think that's
going to get his attention it's going to
wow him that they've built him a much
smaller much worse non-functional rocket
ship i mean even the size of it it's a
joke that recently elon musk posted like
about the real rockets that he builds um
and i'm i'm including it here and i did
you the service of adding in their
rocket ship for scale to help you
understand what we're dealing with here
they're gonna drive this up to the
factory and drop it at the doorstep i
don't even know if anyone's gonna notice
in fact if you stack six of their fake
rockets you still end up going nowhere
this is the new strategy of
cryptocurrency in 2022 guys these people
realized it's not actually about doing
anything it's just about getting elon
musk to retweet you so that idiots will
put their money in and lose it all as
you sell off and get rich so now that
you're kind of up to speed about this
whole scheme let's talk about fox
business which is a mainstream investing
channel who for some unknown reason
brought on elon goat token to the show
called making money with charles payne
now i do want to be clear the elon goat
team says that this was not a paid ad
and on charles's show this is not
labeled an ad or paid programming so
they claim it's earned media and i also
have to tell you that charles payne has
gotten in trouble in the past for not
disclosing that he's been paid to push
worthless stocks he even got fined by
the sec but i'm sure this time is
different let's watch together and tell
me what you think all right hey let me
walk walk us through how this project
came about guys it started with a really
crazy viral idea uh there are a lot of
tokens out there that are seeking elon
musk's attention every day he's given it
to many
and we just thought the best way to do
it would be to do something that no one
else has ever done before and build
something really really cool that would
go viral and get everyone involved and
build a lot of energy and hopefully
spark his interest and noticing us in a
sea of so many others this is so
pathetic this whole company or
cryptocurrency the whole goal of it is
to get a guy to notice them these people
are down so bad to daddy musk and by the
way get a load of these guys in lab
coats behind them that i guess we're
told to stand behind them for the shot i
mean what are they doing like quick
carry a clipboard that'll make them want
to invest that'll make them think we're
serious businessmen and then next comes
maybe the funniest part of all of this
this guy charles payne asks the obvious
has elon musk noticed you guys do you
know the elon musk has actually seen it
yet
we don't know for sure we've trended
very high on his twitter we've ranked
top on his twitter feed which i know
he's very active on so many times uh
we've had you know over probably over a
million views now uh on his twitter so
there's a good chance that he's seen it
we know that there's a lot of tesla
employees that are holders of the token
and spacex hold spacex holders i'm sorry
that are interested in the project and
uh
more than anything what's most important
is that when we deliver it in austin
texas in around a month from now that he
comes out and takes a look at it or
recognizes it in some way that's what's
uh that's what's most important i mean
it's at this point you almost feel bad
for them until you realize that this is
all a big money-making scheme of theirs
like this isn't a sad attempt to get a
guy's attention for no reason this is a
sad attempt to get a guy's attention to
get rich right this is what people think
finance is all about now this is how you
get rich these days you invest in
non-functional rockets so that you're
rich as you get all your other friends
to invest because they see elon musk
tweet about it i guess because make no
mistake
that is what this is all about as you'll
hear now here's the thing and corey
maybe you could chime in on this the
crypto critics and even fans i gotta
tell you are saying there's too many
coins just 19 000 of them so what
justifies yours
what we're doing it for in the utility
there's a lot of coins made every day
they're called pumps and dumps in this
market a lot of them don't last they're
you know they stick around for a day to
three days maybe even a week
and it
people just go into it swing trade hope
to make it you know a quick buck however
like our coin where the utility that
we're introducing to it who we're doing
it for how big this is i mean we've
we've started a crazy community you know
and we refer to it as like you know the
bitcoin community we have got most of
our holders since day one still holding
our token and bringing them you know
their grandmas their family their
friends you know people
often in their life savings pretty much
and this is where things get really dark
this co-founder apparently knows his
community is getting their family
members to invest their life savings but
doesn't see a problem with it because
of the utility
what gives you the confidence that
someone should for instance bring their
grandmother in it with their life
savings is that we we have a huge
community behind us so you know think
about the utility we're the only token
out there that has a board of advisory
you know like you know that came into
crypto have never been part of the
project that actually see the beneficial
side of this now you gotta love here how
they subtly put up the price charts that
show that um in four months from january
7th to april 25th
the price has fallen by 50
which means investors who put their life
savings in the grannies their value
dropped by 50 percent but does charles
payne making money with charles payne
point that out
no he says he likes the art well i got
to tell you you know i'm just i'm a
crypto novice but i i'm a lover of art
and i think uh the sculpture is
beautiful i hope musk sees it and
appreciates it and good luck to you guys
ash and corey appreciate it
wow
this is without a doubt one of the best
examples of why crypto is getting
ridiculed by so many people
as just being full of scams and pump and
dumps it's because of projects like this
with no actual business plan just a
marketing idea just the idea just to
shill it as much as you can
those are the people getting featured on
mainstream investing outlets like this
this is an embarrassment you look silly
and you should be ashamed of yourself